غنائم خوذات الدروع الواقية للبدن
طائرات
[موسيقى
] تركها جيش أفغانستان والولايات
المتحدة تندفع للخروج من
أطول حرب أمريكية ، وتقول الولايات المتحدة إنها دمرت
ما لم تستطع تحمله عندما
غادر آخر حذاء أمريكي الأرض من
مطار كابول الدولي.  لدينا أيضًا
معدات منزوعة السلاح
لم نقم بإحضارها في أه
من المطار تضمنت عددًا من
m-raps
تصل إلى 70 mraps التي قمنا بتفكيكها
ولن يتم استخدامها مرة أخرى من قبل أي شخص. 27 أه
همفي مركبة تكتيكية
صغيرة  لن يتم قيادتها مرة أخرى ،
بالإضافة إلى ذلك
، هناك
73 طائرة
لن تطير هذه الطائرات مرة أخرى أبدًا
على الرغم من أن مركبات الناتو المدرعة هذه
قد تم إنقاذها بنجاح ،
ولكن بعد 20 عامًا من الهجمات الإرهابية
والقتل السياسي ، قام
طالبان المنتصر بإحداث تصالحية  لهجة
في نفس مطار
أفغانستان ، تريد إمارة أفغانستان الإسلامية
علاقات جيدة مع الأمريكيين من
خلال الدبلوماسية ولكن  الأمريكيون
فشلوا هنا ، فشلوا من
الناحية العسكرية ، فشلوا في
تحقيق أهدافهم ،
لكن إمارة أفغانستان الإسلامية
تريد أن تكون لها علاقات جيدة مع
العالم كله نيابة عن الأمة ،
قال المتحدث باسم طالبان
إنه كرر الأوامر لقوات طالبان
الخاصة بمعالجة حتى.  أعداء أفغانستان السابقون
مع
الاحترام أناشد جنودنا جميعًا أن يعاملوا
الناس معاملة حسنة لأن الناس لهم
الحق في السلام أن يتحدوا ونحن
خدام للأمة يجب ألا
نقمع الناس الذين
قالهم في كابول بعضهم احتفل
بالانسحاب الأمريكي معهم.  إطلاق النار
في وضح النهار وفي ظل الخوف المستمر من
سادة طالبان الجدد في المدينة
استجابة أكثر صمتًا ،
من الجيد أن انسحب الأمريكيون
من البلاد ، وعليهم السماح للأفغان
بمناقشة ما سوف يتفقون عليه
وكيف سيشكلون
حكومة يجب أن تكون الحكومة شاملة
ومقبولة  كل أفغانستان قال
إن طالبان وعدت بتسليم
ذلك والسماح لأي شخص يريد المغادرة
بالذهاب  إن وجود ما لا يقل عن مائة
أمريكي لا يزالون محاصرين في أفغانستان تعتمد
إدارتهم المستقبلية والمساعدات
والتجارة على ذلك
الفشل في تحقيق ذلك سيؤدي حتما
إلى انتصار مدلل
سام كايلي سي إن إن الدوحة